the great Renaissance artist Leonardo da
Vinci was born near Florence known
throughout Europe he was employed by the
King of France late in his life he died
in on was in the Lua da Vinci is one of
over a hundred thousand notable people
whose birth places and death beds have
been mapped in this animation it's the
work of a team led by Maximilian Sheikh
based at the University of Texas the
team wanted to chart hundreds of years
of culture births are blue deaths are
red let's start in the far east
this is 17th century Japan just opening
up to the west
many of these names are Christian
missionaries to the country some
persecuted here for their faith in 19th
century Australia migration from Europe
increases the traffic if you watch this
full screen you might make out some
names among them the infamous bushranger
Ned Kelly born in the 1850s his father
was Irish transported to Australia for
stealing pigs
back in time now to the Roman Empire
bear goes Galen physician and surgeon on
his way from Greece to settle in Rome
the powerful Roman Empire drew learned
people in from all over Europe and
beyond cultural sub centers began to
emerge like Cordoba in Spain and Paris
and Avignon in France
from the 12th century onwards all roads
no longer lead to Rome migrations
between other places are common it's a
little like a map of budget airline
destinations
as time goes on we can see that Paris
attracts far more cultural migrants than
other French cities whereas in Germany
several centers compete evenly for
migrants attention even small towns can
be attractive cultural centers look at
the Cote d'Azur in southern France
popular since the late 19th century
these data are from freebase calm a
catalogue of well-known people and
places owned by Google
in the 1600s many European born
explorers looked West striking out to
the Americas
among them a fur trader originally from
the English countryside governor's from
Spain and France looking after islands
in the West Indies and military men
these are early settlers and military
folk you might recognize some of these
names on the left there goes John
Washington great-grandfather of George
Washington the first president of the
United States John was born in Essex
England the trend was to move from the
rural European countryside to the
burgeoning cities of the US Boston New
York Washington hosts two more deaths in
red than births in blue but that starts
to change look at all the blue now as
people build communities and the
population on the East Coast expands
most often people move into and along
river valleys
from the 18th century onwards gradually
look how people are starting to move to
the west coast and living out their days
there
that little cluster on the coast is San
Francisco
transport links make it easier to get
from one coast to the other first trains
and then affordable cars around the
1920s there are still more births than
deaths on the East Coast notable people
begin to flock to mecca's like Hollywood
in Los Angeles this depiction makes
clearer the pull of the West Coast
cultural centers where people move
during their lifetimes and many
well-known names look for a haven for
their twilight years
next the team would like to look at how
Enlightenment thinking and the religious
landscape overlap with their cultural
maps